python 3.10's match statement is not a
switch case statement
this is probably the biggest
misconception about the match statement
and about any new feature in python 3.10
yeah python finally got its own switch
case finally i can
the purpose of the match statement is
not to be a glorified switch case
yes you could use the match statement in
a way that sort of looks like a switch
case but do you really think they would
add this whole new feature to the
language so that you could write match
case like this
instead of the equivalent less indented
and shorter code using if lf and else
don't get me wrong there are plenty of
wonky features in python but adding in a
longer way to do an if statement is not
one of them
but you might say wait i know a language
that does have a switch case statement
and in that language let's just use c
for example there's an actual
performance benefit to using a switch
statement
instead of checking cases one by one
the numerical value of the x determines
an immediate jump to the correct clause
while python could technically implement
this behavior in the special case that
all the cases are compile time integral
constants it's unlikely that a
performance optimization like that would
be added into python anytime soon for
now and for the foreseeable future it
really is just a bunch of if else checks
if you really had a lot of cases and you
didn't want to spend the time doing if
else checks and you wanted to be able to
put in an int and just immediately jump
to the correct code you can do something
like that using this kind of pattern
make a function for each of the code
bodies that you want to use then use a
dictionary mapping each int to the code
you want it to run
then instead of using a match or using a
bunch of if checks in your function
just look up the value you want in the
dictionary which gives you the code that
you should call and then call that as a
function
morally speaking this dictionary is
acting like the jump table that would be
used to make the c code fast
it provides you a constant time lookup
of the code to run next and it prevents
you from having to do a bunch of if
checks the catch of course is that
unless you have a huge number of cases
this is probably going to be slower
a real jump table would just use a
linear function of the key to tell you
how many bytes ahead in memory to jump
immediately to find the next instruction
this is of course not at all what a
python dictionary does there's hashing
involved and all kinds of other stuff
which is needlessly slowing the program
down
so you're probably not ever going to
actually want to do this
but if you do think you have enough
cases where you would actually want to
do this make sure to measure first doing
this absolutely destroys the readability
of your code
so please don't do this unless you've
actually measured your code and seen a
significant performance improvement
so if the match statement just
translates to a bunch of if else checks
under the hood
and it doesn't have any performance
benefits like a switch statement then
what's it good for
well look no further than the actual
name of the feature structural pattern
matching
i think the biggest use case for the
match statement is matching inside a
tree-like structure
most notably i'm talking about abstract
syntax trees and concrete syntax trees
abstract and concrete syntax trees break
up code in this case python code into a
tree-like structure the tree is a
recursive data structure where each node
in the tree breaks down a part of the
code into a primitive of the language
here's the abstract syntax tree for this
code
we have a module whose body is a
sequence of assignments the first
assignment assigns the name a to the
constant value hello the second
assignment
assigns the name b
to the constant value subscribe a
concrete syntax tree does basically the
same thing except it also keeps track of
enough information to be able to
reconstruct the original source it keeps
track of what kind of parentheses you
used what kind of white space you used
and it even keeps track of comments
in a previous video i already talked
about how you can use the built-in ast
library to create custom code rules for
your code base but the rules were very
simple and didn't depend on any of the
formatting of your code
in this video we'll see how we can use
libcst which is a concrete syntax tree
library in conjunction with the match
statement in order to match a more
realistically complex situation
have you seen this popular example
floating around is true true true equal
to true true true
the answer is
true true
false
the reason is because it's being parsed
like this it sees a tuple of true true
and the boolean expression does true
equal to the tuple of true true true so
true true and false of course if you put
parentheses like this then you'll get
the answer you were probably expecting
okay let's use the match statement in
order to detect this scenario
let's start by creating a visitor class
inheriting from cst visitor
if we override one of the visit
underscore methods then the library will
call this method for every node of that
type that it finds so in this case it'll
call this function for every tuple that
it finds in the cst in this example code
there are two tuples there's the whole
expression which remember evaluated to
true true false and there's this tuple
we parse the code to get a root object
and then ask that object to visit using
our visitor as expected we get two calls
to the visit tuple function
let's also print out the dump of the cst
so we know what we're trying to match
against even though this was just from a
single line of code the cst for this is
actually quite large so we do have to
kind of know what we're looking for
at this stage we're just looking at the
structure of how the tuple and the
comparison interact so let's turn off
these extra options so here's kind of
the pattern that we're looking for we
have a tuple
the tuple has some number of elements
and the last element in the tuple is a
comparison
whose comparison target is comparing
against another tuple
we're trying to match that tree-like
structure using the match statement so
we're looking for a tuple whose elements
are
a sequence we don't care what the first
elements are but there's at least one
and the last element has a value which
is a comparison and it's just a single
comparison not a multiple comparison
where the operator is equals
and it is comparing against another
tuple
zooming out here's what we got so far
okay it's definitely not pretty but it
is very very similar to the actual cst
printout that we looked at before i
didn't necessarily know what all of
these attributes like elements and
comparisons were i just copied them from
the cst printout and if we go ahead and
run it on our example then indeed we see
that it matches on the other hand if we
put in the parentheses then we see that
it does not match but technically we
haven't used anything about the concrete
syntax yet everything here is part of
the abstract syntax tree so why am i
using a concrete syntax tree well what
if someone did this no matter how silly
it seems to me to try to do something
like this if someone put explicit parens
around this then that probably is what
they intended
so in that case i would not want to
match and i would not want to throw an
error but these outside parens are
redundant an abstract syntax tree would
not see them at all
so if i use the built-in ast module i
couldn't tell whether or not they used
parens that's why i'm using the cst
let's go back to the dump to see where
those parents show up well here they are
and if i scroll up to see what that
corresponds to it looks like it's an
attribute of this comparison node
so let's go back up to our match
statement and add in the additional
complexity we only want to match this
structure if the left paren and right
paren fields are empty meaning they did
not put explicit parens now when we run
the code on all three examples we get
the right answer each time if they left
it in this ambiguous state they get an
error but if they put brands here
or here then there's no error let's take
a step back now and look at the
complexity that we've created
no one is denying it this code is
complex we need to see a tuple with some
number of elements and the last element
needs to be a comparison and the
comparison needs to have a comparison
target that uses equals and is comparing
to another tuple and there needs to be
no other parentheses that is undeniably
a complex thing that we're trying to
match against however this is pretty
close to essential complexity you pretty
much can't describe all the cases that
you do and don't want to match against
without involving this much complexity
the real test for whether this is
acceptable is to compare against what
the code would have had to look like if
we use the alternative if checks
well here is the equivalent set of if
checks i need a tuple that has at least
two elements the last of which is a
comparison that does not have left or
right parentheses
that's a single comparison not a
multi-comparison comparing for equality
against another tuple i don't know about
you but i find this code much harder to
write and much much harder to read
it would be so easy to
get the order of these arguments wrong
or make a typo on the length or make a
typo on the index or to get confused
about whether or not i actually need
these parentheses here and so on and so
on this code is definitely shorter than
the other one but i think this one is
much clearer and that is the purpose of
the match statement
the match statement is for matching
against the structure of an object there
are no indices to mess up you just need
to show python what the structure that
you're looking for looks like
thank you for watching i hope you have a
little bit better understanding of
structural pattern matching in python
now
please let me know what you think in the
comments do you think that this match
code is more readable than the if checks
even if it is more readable do you think
it was worth adding a whole new feature
to the language
thank you to my patrons and donors for
supporting me if you like my content
please consider subscribing and if you
especially like my content please
consider becoming a patron have
questions about the new features in
python 310 join my discord slap that
like button an odd number of times and i
will see you next time